You can use Google Analytics
to answer questions like
how do users download my app?
So over here in the dashboard
you see the Acquisition menu,
expand it, New Users.
We see the new users for
the time period, and we can scroll
down to see their locations.
How the App Marketplace shows
where users downloaded your app.
And you can get a day-by-day breakdown.
So com.androidvending is the Play Store,
so
here we see that most of the downloads
came from the Play Store.
And then you can scroll down this
page to get the accumulated data.
So the Sources reports
provide different but
similar views of the same data,
showing where users got your app.
So the All shows all
the places they got the app.
Google Play shows the sessions
where the users downloaded the app
from Google Play.
And iTunes will show a similar thing for
iTunes.
We can look at the Google Play Referral
report to see workflow representation
of where people came from to get to
the Play store to install the app.
So, Google organic.
We see here we had 111 Play Store Views,
which resulted in 60 installs.
So to be able to get reports like this,
you need to do a couple of things.
So the app must be in Google Play,
or also, on iTunes, you can track
conversion tracking from iTunes.
You need to link your Google Analytics
account to Google Play.
So, to link your Analytics
account to Google Play,
go to the Google Play
page in the dashboard.
And you see this information
telling you that report requires
that you link your app
to the Google Play.
And you can just go ahead right from
here and click Set up app linking.
Enter all the data.
And right here,
Get Google Play Developer Console Data.
And if you're doing iOS
Campaign Tracking you would also
enable that one there.
And you save that.
And now your Google Analytics
account is linked to Google Play for
this account ID.
The steps for linking to iTunes
are outlined in the dashboard, too.
So you can go through those steps
here if applicable to your app.
And don't forget to add the code to
your app to send the download hits.
Oops, my bad.
No code needed for
Android Apps and
that's all there is to it.
Now you'll be able to use Google
Analytics to track how people download
your app from the Play Store.
This course doesn't cover
deploying apps to Google Play, so
I'll leave you to investigate this
aspect of Analytics on your own.